hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very excited to have victoria connor
fall on today's episode you might know
her as sierra brady on days of our lives
the soap opera uh she's been on the show
for years she has the wildest storylines
we talk about just the ecosystem of
working on something like a soap opera
how she's had to
record
70 some pages of dialogue in a day like
the generated content in that world is
wild also her character is going through
something you know we've all probably
experienced um having a devil baby just
the classic rite of passage for every
young woman we also talk about growing
up in brooklyn and expediting her
maturity uh in that also wild ecosystem
and of course i had to touch on the fact
that she was in uh the let me get it
correctly so i don't say it incorrectly
miss poland
usa
actually
no spoilers but she won
she is absolutely lovely we have a
really great conversation about just her
views on the world social media uh and
the wild and wonderful ride of being on
such an iconic program so enjoy this
episode of not too deep with victoria
connor fall
[Music]
and we're in victoria it is so awesome
to talk to you so awesome to be here
thank you so much for having me of
course okay i want to get into
everything that you're up to now first
of all i have to give my condolences i
just saw that your car got broken into
oh my gosh yes what happened
and are you okay oh i'm totally fine i
don't like to let things that i can't
control control me and my emotions
so i took it with a grain of salt i am a
kind
i i was upset i i was also upset at the
bad job they did because they
robbed me but they were very messy about
it they took my little uh tv console but
they broke it on the way out so it's not
worth that much now
you're gonna do it right i feel a little
bit protective
um
but i was actually at mammoth over the
weekend
for a little snowboarding trip and i
come back and my car is just broken into
they took everything uh even my
energizer
wow your hand sanitizer too
i didn't realize it was that big of a
commodity still but oh well like they
they took my hand sanitizer and
everything wow
yeah
material things are material things so i
can replace them as long as no one's
hurt and everyone is okay i'm praying
that the people who stole them maybe
they really needed money and and
they get out of it who cares that's a
great perspective to have on all of it
there's also
you're born and raised in brooklyn yes i
am okay so you are used to um
wild card events happening i would say
to say the least i think growing up in
brooklyn helped prepare me to react
appropriately to this situation so yeah
i'm curious what that's like to grow up
in brooklyn i lived there after college
but only spent a few years there so
what's it like to be born and raised
i mean
it's awesome i have so much brooklyn
pride um
it really shapes you into
just being a like loving accepting
human i i never you know i grew up
surrounded in culture i grew up uh
immersed in art and film and
music and and
just living
at the center of where all that breathes
is so special um so i never really had
the
suburban like uh
you know drying chalk and playing
hopscotch sidewalk we had to look both
ways before we crossed the street or
we'd be sprawled out on the sidelines
um it taught me diligence i guess it
taught me uh how to be very aware of my
surroundings i remember i would take the
subway to middle school alone when i was
like 13. um
and most 13 year olds don't have to
worry about the subway but i remember i
came up with this little trick i would
take a compact mirror remind you i
wasn't wearing makeup at the time but i
didn't pretending to do my makeup while
i look at
the surroundings behind me it made me
feel like such a spy made me feel like
that's a little badass
i love it like i'm a genius and no one
will ever know
unmessed with a bull thank you very much
is there any part of you that craves any
of that suburban stuff is there any part
of you because you're still in brooklyn
now are you at all thinking about making
the los angeles jump or any of that i'm
in los angeles oh you're in los angeles
now yeah i've been joking
for about five years now oh okay great
but i'm back in brooklyn all the time
because i actually find it's the
opposite i moved out to california loved
it for like a year and i started
creating a home again
uh so i try to go out four or five times
a year i'm always there that's great but
i do love
the suburban like beach life out here
and the hikes and the
the quiet uh i guess i didn't really run
away from the crime because you're
still here and escape the crime but
i escaped the sirens
there's a sense of quietness here of
like a little bit more stillness than
what you get in brooklyn yeah for sure
i'm curious how did you i mean growing
up in a place like that like you said
you're surrounded by arts and culture
and all of that how did you get into
into the arts into entertainment was
there like a point in time where you
were like i want to perform i want to
act i want to be involved in the arts
yeah um i was always drawn to the drama
department in school
so i would always audition for the plays
and sign up for drama club and it was
always very much a hobby of mine i
didn't think that i could actually you
know make a career out of it it's like
i don't know i heard the stories of oh
we were
discovered at a coffee shop or not i was
waiting for my coffee shop moment i'm
like someone tired
there's a stack of headshots at
starbucks with you saying hello
here's my resume um but then i went to
um laguardia
yeah same school this school has a
roster of very illustrious artistic
individuals yeah and even then i didn't
think that i could make anything out of
it because i'm like oh it's the one in a
million chance
then
senior year of high school we had a
showcase where a bunch of agencies would
watch us perform a monologue and we were
scouted afterwards and i was scouted and
they were like hey what do you think
about moving to los angeles and becoming
a full-time actor and i was like you
know what terrified but okay
let me try
amazing i mean that must have been so
intimidating too oh for sure i was
freshly 19 when i moved out here wow um
i drove out here from brooklyn actually
after having my license for four months
perfect i'm pretty palsy yeah i drove
through in the middle of the worst
snowstorm of the century apparently i
was like driving on six inches of ice in
tennessee
um
so weird uh but yeah i got here i didn't
know anybody i kind of just hustled did
my thing
did the whole waitressing thing until i
started booking uh movies nice well
obviously
i want to talk about days of our lives
um
how did this happen what was this
audition process like what was were you
ever even considering projects like this
um
no i never
i didn't know that they were looking for
someone like me in a soap opera you
think you know everything is already so
established the cast is family it's a
tight-knit group everyone has known them
for 60 years yeah um
and so i get this audition and i was
really excited because it was a two-year
contract and i'm like oh my god if i got
this then i could fully quit my
waitressing job i can just like
completely transition and have like 200
episodes of a tv show under my belt that
is insanity so i was really excited
though i didn't expect it um it was
wild to me it was so glamorous the whole
idea yeah i get this audition
and normally you hear back
after like four days i heard nothing so
i'm like okay on to the next one yeah a
month later they're like hey we want to
see you again like a month okay all
right
so i go in again
and i have the wrong audition prepared
so i'm here with my audition i have a
five-page scene and then i'm looking
around and all these other girls are
uh murmuring completely different lines
and i'm like oh no what do your sides
look like queen because i might don't
look like that and so i freaked out um i
asked marnie the casting director to see
me last because i needed to prepare it
oh nightmare so sweet they were like
here you can use my script
if you need me to so supportive and
lovely um i ended up nailing it and they
came
they brought me back again a week later
right wow and then i didn't hear from
them for another month
this is a very like playing hard to get
scenario really wanted me to lust after
them
give me some and take it away
um
so i get to the end of this two months
thing and i audition i go straight to
producers after producers i go and test
which i had no idea what it was at the
time i was terrified it was my first
test
and that just means that i go on set
with the real actors and i read
the story
in front of the cameras and they record
it and they watch it over like it's like
shooting an episode but yeah yeah you
know i was so intimidated um we all got
a chance to rehearse except for me
because they used me as the guinea pig
to show us the blocking so excuse me of
the guinea pig and then they were like
all right let's record and then they
recorded my thing and i'm like all right
that was my rehearsal okay i'm ready to
record now they're like no babes we're
moving on that was your final take
this is so wonderful such my luck
they're putting you through it and then
so normally after you test you're
supposed to know after that test mm-hmm
they made us test again so they had
obsessed with seven girls and then they
brought back in again to test with three
girls and at that point i'm like if i
don't get this then i'm gonna
cry because i put so much into this
and i was on my way to my waitressing
job when i got the call that i booked it
my manager calls me and he's like hey hi
he's like guess who the new sierra brady
is i'm like no way and it was me i was
so excited i had to uber to work because
i couldn't
drive i was freaking out yeah
that's i mean after all of that uh if
your manager had called you and been
like it was the other girl that got it
congrats
okay you know what give it to the
universe on to the next because at that
point it's either have a mental
breakdown or be completely okay with it
so no okay i'm so curious because days
of our lives has been on since like the
60s like when you get this audition in
the first place how familiar were you
with the show like did you go back and
do like i'm gonna study these episodes
is it truly a billion of them to look at
um i
didn't know what the show was it was
actually the only soap opera i was aware
of because um my mother is an immigrant
and so she immigrated here from poland
and when she got to america she would
watch days of our lives every single
day to learn english language so
i was surrounded in it growing up oh my
god my favorite characters on the show
happened to be my parents on the show it
was a whole thing
this must be amazing for her oh my god
she's loving it
but yeah so i was aware of the show i
wasn't i didn't know the storyline in
detail i remembered some of it but
i i ended up not doing much research
until i got there because i didn't want
to
i was replacing another actress okay
so i didn't want to
accidentally like watch her and pick up
any character traits i wanted the
character to be my own and kind of see
what i can do with her yeah i didn't
like to research i kind of um i met
christian alfonzo the woman who plays my
mother when i got there and she was so
welcoming and wonderful and she brought
me in her dressing room and she was like
baby i know this mary but i got you i'm
gonna put you under my wing okay she
gave me a rundown of the character the
character's history uh
her yeah personality traits down to like
her favorite color it was crazy he
really put me through the brady boot
camp
amazing yeah
yeah
i'm curious because the experience of be
i mean you've done a lot of other
projects but the experience of being on
a soap opera it's so intense there's
episodes every day there's story lines
like how it blows my mind that they're
still able to conceptualize new
storylines in this world yeah what's the
intensity of the work uh because there's
so much content that they're generating
it's very intense i will say uh a lot
harder for me to adjust to in the
beginning um mainly because
personally as an actress when i perform
i like to draw on
my own circumstances and and what i was
emoting in that time and
sew it into my work sure with soap
operas
my character for example was kidnapped
on seven different occasions
he's been
set on fire four times by her cousin you
know my cousin has never tried to set me
on fire thankfully
but it's good that you don't have an
actual experience you can draw
yeah you know my character is also in
love with a serial killer a man who like
strangles women for a living oh my god
really hard to uh make it realistic as
victoria so um
i just strip it down and i
try to make it as real and raw as
possible emotion-wise but story-wise
it's uh it is hard and and the sheer
amount of dialogue we have is
mind-blowing um
capable of filming three episodes in a
day collectively i remember the most i
ever had in one day was like
73 pages of dialogue
oh my god and they don't give us the
scripts until like three days before
we're supposed to shoot so it's my life
is constantly like
wake up at six go shoot till five come
home eat memorize my stuff go to bed
repeat it's crazy oh my god
yeah that's wild um also yeah your
storyline currently there's a devil baby
involved in this yeah what's going on
here
oh let me tell you my baby is the most
sought after baby in all of hell
the devil came from the gate and said i
want your baby and this devil is now
possessing everyone in town and trying
to get their human vessels to steal my
baby
i love it
absolutely i love like there's such a
part of my language like [ __ ] with
soap operas that they're just like
really throwing out the rules of the
universe and letting whatever fly and
there's something really fun about that
oh my god it's so fun all of a sudden
paranormal activity exists the devil is
quite literally real
um
and it's after my child for some reason
i don't know
and you for this part
i mean not only is it absolutely wild
but
it's also rewarding you want a daytime
emmy for this right
yes yeah that's uh talking about that
that must be crazy has that really set
in for you
i don't know i don't think it has i mean
my friends do a lovely job at reminding
me like when we're out and about they're
like hey
this is victoria connor she's an enemy
winning actor and i'm like you guys
please be
too much quiet um i don't think it has
set in it was wild and crazy um for the
first couple of weeks a couple of months
after yeah um
just because i was still so freshly
living in the high of it i guess yeah
but now that the high is gone the actual
fact of the matter has not set in and
it's been
almost a year
while so i don't
think it's ever gonna i think i'm just
always i mean miami is on my mantel i'm
looking at it now and it doesn't you
know make me feel i'm like what's up
that's a beautiful looking paperweight
like wow
i was really holding down all those
papers sorry
because also i just not to knock um
the academy or award shows or anything
like that i'm i'm so grateful and
humbled and appreciative but i've also
seen so many deserving artists not
recognized in that capacity so then it's
like hey like i don't i don't know if my
miami definitely doesn't make me better
than anyone it doesn't make me more
talented it just means that i happen to
be chosen by the academy that year
because of a storyline or because of one
certain performance so i don't like to
have it way too heavily
on my chest or or you know in my actor
resume like yeah it's super cool i'm so
grateful but at the same time
it can't mean everything you know yeah
you know how old when he got his first
oscar and leo's been deserving it since
what's being gilbert great like right
yeah so i i like to take it uh lightly
with that
you have a very grounded point of view
about it which is really cool
um i'm also curious just about like the
fan interactions or the community
interactions because it's yeah such a
long-standing series i'm sure you've had
some
interesting interactions with
is there any that stick out to you
yeah i
so i get very very overwhelmed with
social media um my twitter account is
still active but i've deleted it from my
phone and it's been deleted for almost
three years now i don't have facebook i
don't have snapchat i don't have
anything i have instagram which i'm good
at stories because it's very like in the
moment and it keeps me you know happier
and relevant
um
but
the fans that
they are so die hard because they have
been watching the show for so long that
it it genuinely feels like family to
them yeah um
so i mean i don't have any specifics but
there are some fans who think
the show is real life
and so
the other day
it's funny it's so funny to me
since my character is pregnant on the
show yeah i am not pregnant but
a fam commented on my picture being like
this pregnancy weight looks beautiful on
you i'm so happy that you're so healthy
in this pregnancy you look beautiful
stay safe and i'm like
you do know that i'm not but okay okay
all right i see i see i guess this is a
compliment thank you oh you're telling
me that i'm glowing i love it thank you
well i'm also curious because the the
workload like you said sounds so intense
what do you do when you're not working
what's your go-to are you watching
anything are you going out you said you
were out of town over like a couple days
ago like what's your go-to
oh man i like to do everything i'm
pretty eclectic uh in terms of what i
like to do i really love exercising
that's something that i do a lot um
kickboxing in particular so i will go
hiking i will do my kickboxing
um i do love watching movies right now
i'm obsessed with euphoria oh my god
oh my god um yellow jacket is good
dexter uh new blood is good there are so
many things that i love to watch
um
i love going to the cinema now that we
can again yeah yeah um
yeah traveling
snowboarding
to the ocean
to the window to the wall
that's great i mean it's nice to yeah
shake your brain up a little bit i mean
like you said you're on set so much and
you're consuming so many lines and
scenes and
moments that getting connected to the
real world i'm sure is is huge
what else are you working on or are
there things that you want to be working
on because i know what was it that you
were before the pandemic like when your
contract ran out you had kind of like
wanted to try something else
yeah uh oh such timing yeah right so i
my contract was up after years and i was
ready to kind of
move on dip my toe into other projects i
missed being on a movie set versus a
soap set um
it's a very different experience and and
ultimately i would have wanted to do
like a location shoot yeah
then two weeks later they shut down the
world completely
and then
10 months after that they picked
production back up mind you all of us
were unemployed this was still back
before we even you know it was it was
really hard
and um they asked to have me back as a
contract player and i'm like well this
is kind of tricky because i didn't even
have a chance i know i've been away for
10 months but
had a chance to dip my toe yeah um so i
agreed to a 16-week contract and then
after that they wanted me back for
another year and i was like hey
i can't do it like i did for a reason
just because
like i love y'all appreciate you so much
but understand me and where i'm coming
from my artistic integrity was no longer
being fulfilled i i needed to change a
switch up
so they agreed to have me not on
contract uh to have me as a recurring so
i've been doing that for a couple of
months so i'm very grateful i've been
auditioning in the meantime auditions
are really slow right now yeah
yeah so it's it's like
i've gotten a couple of almost a couple
of films um i do have something on the
horizon a friend of mine is actually
producing a film in the south
and he pitched it to me i can't really
talk much about that or the storyline
but i like it so i think i'm gonna go
ahead and
take some time off and do that so
i might be
putting on my cowgirl hat next and going
very fun okay well we won't spoil any of
the secrets um we're gonna take a quick
break when we get back guess what i have
a bunch more questions for you amazing
love to answer we'll be right back with
more not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us a
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay
victoria i have to ask
uh
miss poland usa
what happened here
what is this
why does this come up when i google you
oh no if i could tell google to remove
it oh no i when i was in college i did
the miss new jersey pageants i'm from
jersey and yeah it's like one of the
things that comes up every time and so
and i wish i could erase it completely
from the internet
yeah um so
my
mother uh was
like a self-proclaimed pageant mom even
though i wasn't a pageant kid she really
wanted me to do it so in order to
qualify for miss new york it wasn't even
a physical pageant or a miss poland new
york whatever yeah you just submitted my
um picture with a little bio she wrote
it for me didn't tell me she was doing
it and i come home from school one day
she's like yo how school i'm like oh
good oh by the way you're miss paul in
new york now i'm like what
what
what
she's like yeah you're gonna be
competing in the miss poland universe
pageant uh in uh two months from now oh
my god good to know thanks um
so she signs me up for it and i go and
when i tell you i i didn't
it's not like i did it in a
disrespectful way but i i don't give a
[ __ ] about it at all yeah like i showed
up in sneakers and a leather jacket and
like not to knock you know anyone who
who loves the pageant life but like
these girls were you know
all done up and i'm not really the kind
to like being done up like that sure
sure so
they're all trying so hard they fly from
arizona they fly from california they
fly into new york i'm everywhere yeah
and i'm like i'm chilling i don't care i
even messed up during uh one of my um
monologues or something it was my it was
supposed to be my turn or i thought it
was my turn it wasn't i walked on and i
grabbed the mic mind you they had called
a completely different girl and i'm like
what oh my god
and they called my name and i won and
i'm like really interested i guess they
loved the quirky goofy
yeah not trying too hard attitude i
don't know but the girls cried once they
called my name like they were very upset
that they
i i shouldn't have one i really wanted
someone a friend of mine was in it and
she wanted to win so badly she tried
five times and i was holding her hand
and i'm like you got this you got this
and then they called my name and i was
like oh [ __ ]
i'm so sorry
um so i'm assuming that the pageant
world is now out of your system yeah
okay okay good i mean you gotta try it
once it's a wild world and the people
that make it their full-time thing i'm
just fascinated by it you know it's like
so not something i connect to but the
people that know it's a true skill to
know how to do that stuff it's a lot of
mental commitment yeah
you know just to think
about taking it seriously it would be a
lot of stress and pressure it's kind of
like the modeling world i guess but even
more pressure i have no idea there's
just
i i i never want to sign myself up for
anything that will judge me based on my
beauty because i feel like i have
way more to offer than just what i was
born with um totally so yeah but it's
great yeah it was fun it was a fun
experience i yeah you have to kind of
smile at all of it because it is like
it's a world in which everyone's really
truly trying
um okay what's this dance situation
going on with your brother-in-law
oh my gosh yeah yeah what is this are
you into is it ballroom dancing is it
okay what is this so i did ballroom
dance when i was younger okay but i very
much though i'm polish i'm as as white
as white gets i did my ancestry i'm like
99 polish one percent finish oh wow i
really identify and appreciate latin
culture so
most of the time in my home i will
listen to latin pop
um
i eat
you know latin food i i dance latin
dance i always go to
uh salsa night whenever it's around like
it's it's such a passion of mine and my
brother-in-law is puerto rican and he is
a professional dance instructor and
sister owns a ballroom dance clothing
company and like the way they met was
sober magic it was at a competition a
dance competition and he saw her i
thought she was cute and he like wanted
to give her a present so he was emceeing
and he handed her a light bulb like from
the mc podium to
represent a flower i don't know they
were so cute
and now they're you know married and um
they host this thing called latin
fridays together so at his dance studio
he performs sometimes with um
you know the models that model her
dresses and they wear her dresses she'll
sell her apparel and he will perform and
i was in town once and they were like
here's a funny idea you've always wanted
to learn how to you know do a big
professional dance
latin friday's coming up you're going
what if we you know market it as like
emmy winning actress victoria does latin
friday yeah i loved it so he taught me
the routine in
five hours over the three days
um and i did it and i was wearing my
sister's clothing it was amazing it was
so much fun
i was so nervous i only performed for
like 60 people mind you i'm on tv every
day in front of millions of people yeah
then the dance was so much more
nerve-wracking than anything i've done
before it was it was really fun oh
that's so sweet yeah what a beautiful
love story oh my god
is dancing with the stars in your future
at all i mean hey have they come
knocking
open the door
[Music]
um okay victoria i'm gonna get into the
two questions i ask every single guest
that's on the podcast
um the first is who alive or dead would
you most like to throw cold spaghetti at
yeah real real hard hitting question
here
cold spaghetti i love how specific that
is yeah
we're trying to avoid the burns for
anyone
cold spaghetti and i like to think of
this as just an answer that comes up now
this is something that obviously can
change on a daily basis hourly basis
it's just who in this moment now so the
cold spooky it's meant to be unpleasant
right i would like to technically it's
up to you you can throw it joyously you
can throw it in celebration if you want
it's entirely your intention
okay
even though okay all right this is
you
completely
joyous
intense nothing uh eminem just because
mom's spaghetti is so popular like hey
here's some of my mom's spaghetti and
just shower him in the spaghetti and
then i would throw some on myself too
and i would dance around with eminem in
a field with cold spaghetti
i feel like this has the possibility to
be a plot line
on days of our lives in the future
call the writers yeah
okay the other question every single
guess is to tell us your worst pant
[ __ ] story or like a bathroom
emergency situation
uh but you can only use three words or
like small phrases to describe this
situation so for example
mine is college jogging front lawn
okay yeah
oh okay um
oh you got one okay gas station gas
station
gasoline
oh [ __ ] modern family
well i won't give any follow-up
questions to that i'll let everyone
paint the picture
um yeah with that with modern family and
all that are there dream shows that you
like would love to be on are there
like things in your mind that you
manifest or try to
uh i was on one episode of modern family
once that was so much fun incredible my
story kind of ties into that um
but
i
i mentioned euphoria earlier yeah that
is something that i would love to sink
my teeth into just because of how
riveting the storyline is it's it's it's
very triggering for a lot of people so i
understand why it's
avoided
i actually like the way that they're
airing it out now that there's space in
between because i binged the first
season in one day and i was depressed
for about four weeks
really hard i know that's it's on my
short list of shows to get into but i
know the intensity or i've heard how
intense it is that i'm like i have to be
emotionally prepared i think and
separate it like
time to watch it in increments because
watching it in one day
that was a mistake
it was the reason i called my first
therapist like it there you go
there you go yeah i wonder if therapists
have had uh like an uptick in the amount
of people reaching out to them
specifically triggered by
euphoria something
something
i don't really
see myself being in sitcoms or or you
know cute little comedies i would need
something more serious like any kind of
hbo
um
something that that will really
force me to research and become the
character
yeah something that i played for so long
she's pretty similar to myself um yeah
and and it's very easy for me to
transform into sierra at this point i
want something that will challenge my
ass off i just want to
throw myself in where's victoria no
one's heard from her she's too busy
working on her character
yeah what's your prep like in that kind
of situation like do you sit and really
kind of come up with
the like 4d imaging of this person that
you want to take yourself into yeah i uh
i mostly focus
music music music is so important music
can alter
my mood personally i'm the type of
that's very influenced by music
if i hear something dark and dreary i
can turn into a euphoria character if
i'm listening to walking on sunshine
then you know i will beat that girl
skipping across the lawn laughing at the
girl who pooped her pants on the college
exactly
music helps a lot and and i don't like
to give her like when i work on a
character i give her a little bit of a
back story
i like to
focus on the attitude of the person
because then
it's like what is your actual
personality not how you would react in
the situation what is the character's
personality are they going to cry when
their car gets broken into or are they
going to laugh it off and you know yeah
you work on those specifics and you
really get a well-rounded idea of who
they are something also that's kind of
funny that i like to do is i like to
give my characters um zodiac signs
oh yeah
i'll like my character on days of our
lives as a scorpio as am i uh so it's
that helps me
shape her and who she is but i still do
their birth charts and everything and
i'm like all right this is my character
and that's who i'm playing i'm just now
getting into astrology and i'm so
excited about it but it's also
what's up what sign are you i'm a libra
mediator fair and balanced all that good
stuff
group yeah it's um it's like learning
another language it's pretty wild yeah
i'm so fascinated by all of it but it
really feels like you have to study to
remember everything and get a grasp on
on what it is i've been doing it for
five years now just looking at it
seriously and it's a
it's a lot i still have no idea what i'm
talking about but
yeah
i'm just like are we in retrograde
where's mercury what's going on great
that's why i got robbed yeah
don't make any big plans
[Music]
okay now we have uh
towards the end of the podcast a section
called deep and hot where i ask you a
deep question that we have prepared for
you and for your hot take on kind of
like a topic that we have prepared for
you okay so deep question
when did you know or feel like you were
really growing up
when
when i started
not
[Music]
calling my parents and family members
for advice and help once i started
taking on tasks yeah i was like oh this
is adulting this is my problem i've
figured it out like i got to figure out
how to pay this bill and how to register
my car and how to do all this yeah
that happened kind of early for me i
will say that growing up in brooklyn
we touched on it a bit before but
i i did have to grow up a little bit
faster my childhood was limited just
considering
um i had to be in survival mode to be
safe yeah i mean if you're on a subway
when you're 13 years old like that
throws you into
a big survival situation yeah i had to
worry about being you know sexually
assaulted by random men on the street
that's not something
anyone wants to think about let alone a
13 year old girl so it's like i have to
adjust my mindset um
but i think i i balance it out now very
well because i'm such a big baby like i
love being a kid i'm so [ __ ] immature
i love it
i love it so i'm i'm very much an adult
but i'm also five years old and that's
the perfect happy medium for me i very
much relate to that very much
um okay the hot take that i have for you
which is kind of you talked a touch on
this a little bit earlier i'm curious
about because even in looking
uh doing some research and looking at
everything that you're doing online you
keep kind of a low profile uh on social
media and that kind of stuff i'm curious
what your like hot take or thoughts or
relationship with social media is for
you
i think it can be a very powerful tool
if used the right way i think like every
business i'm like oh let me check their
instagram so that i can find them see
their inventory see where they're
located i think for businesses
it's important um
but i think
and i guess like as an actress i am my
own business right yeah the reason why i
have instagram still to the public eyes
if i
wasn't an actress and i have a little
private one for me and my three friends
and
like that would be it
um
but
i think that personally
hot take i think instagram should be
banned from like people using it
personally because
it really affects mental health in ways
that yeah we all say it like oh it
affects our self-image no it seriously
does it's rewiring the br the brains
of our children and our younger
generations like i have family members
who
are like 12 years old and they're
looking at these girls and they're like
yeah i'm gonna get lip fillers and i'm
gonna get this i'm like your face hasn't
even finished developing like yeah why
are we putting so much pressure on on
the way we look and like
instagram is very much a highlight reel
even for myself i don't post when i'm
feeling depressed i don't post when i'm
feeling whatever because that's my
personal life and i don't want people to
see it but when
people view us
from that platform and that perspective
we perpetuate perfection and that is not
okay and so i hate social media i love
it for businesses but personally if if i
could have in my way i think that we
would all have it deleted and it would
be amazing yeah you have such a great
perspective on everything i feel like
you have a very healthy like attachment
and also awareness of like when you need
to detach from things yeah because i do
i'm with you that i i worry because i
feel like we're still kind of in the
middle of finding out what the actual
like psychological repercussions will be
from all of this yeah so just being
aware of like oh this is a tool i use
for myself as a business versus this is
where i find happiness or value or worth
in any capacity right
um okay last question before we wrap up
if you weren't involved in acting what
do you think you'd be doing
so i've always wanted to be a rock star
hell yeah i think i'd be a rock star for
sure i taught myself how to play guitar
over quarantine nice
so i would find a way to make my
rockstar career happen or um i was
studying criminal law and psychology
before i quit college to become an
actress i did that for like a semester
yeah
so i would be i would have something
to do with like forensic psychology or
or
anything to do with with law and and
criminals i'm very much that like yeah i
love i love yeah order documentaries i i
love watching those so um
so cool i'd have something to do my
career path would be somewhere in that
nice oh there's still time at some point
um victoria this has been so lovely
thank you so much for the conversation
thank you so much conversation as well i
had a blast of course before we wrap up
i'm so excited to hear that you're into
astrology we like to give our uh guests
a little token of our appreciation and
we have a personalized horoscope from us
to you we are not astrologers like i
said this is entirely for fun and
melissa just put it in the chat if you'd
like to read it out
that is so cute oh my god that's a love
language in mind stop it right now okay
here
dear scorpio scorpion and scorpion of
the stars mercury goes direct in your
communication zone this week which
allows you to refocus your energy on the
big picture of what you want to get done
this year
no more devils trying to steal your baby
there you go
written in the stars
i love that so much hold on i'm gonna
take a photo of the chat book book and
because this is just
this
yeah i think it can be interpreted
literally or metaphorically whatever the
baby might represent to you i think he's
beautiful i'm i'm so touched thank you
of course now victoria where can people
see what you're working on or see where
you're at follow you online if you want
them to wherever you are
i have one platform and that is
instagram and it's just my first and
last name victoria conniffle perfect and
people can watch days of our lives every
day every day on the peacock app and nbc
amazing well thank you again this was so
awesome yeah grace thank you so much
this is so much fun of course and we'll
see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye too deep
too deep too deep not too deep with
christ
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music